[Musique]
m
j'arrivais à la fin de mes études
j'avais interne on sait les études de
droit j'ai envie de prendre le large et
partir loin
tous étaient plus ou moins de passer
correctement jusqu'à lors on avait un
très très grand professeur de droit qui
était notre maître à tous m parce qu'il
simplifier tout et tout les éléments
complexes du droit et c'était un homme
excessivement bienveillant et il
enseigne et en afrique et on a voulu le
rejoindre et on est parti avec un groupe
d'étudiants sénégal on s'attendait
absolument pas rien on était jeunes
innocents et c'est vrai que l'on n'a pas
vraiment été déçu
on est arrivé le premier jour sur l'île
de gorée
c'est l'île des esclaves et sur la
pirogue notre guide qui s'applique
babacar nous voyez un petit peu stressé
on était stressés parce qu'il y avait de
la connexion et un edge soirée téléphone
et nous attendent et vous vous avez une
montre une où on a le temps une boutade
mais ça m'a fait un petit peu réfléchi
on a continué le périple on est allé
donner des livres à une école d'enfants
d'enfants sourds sont venus jouer au
rugby avec les enfants et on leur a
apporté des vivres et eux ils nous ont
appris le langage des signes
c'est un moment excessivement fort et
c'est vrai que les enfants qui avaient
entre 8 et 15 ans étaient tous plus ou
moins heureux il faisait tous 30 km à
l'est 30 km retour pour aller à l'école
bon et ce jour là la directrice parce
qu'on l'a interpellé sur le sujet m'a
dit mais ils ne confondent pas le verbe
être et le verbe à moi
et puis on a été reçus par nos étudiants
les étudiants qui étaient nos homologues
qui faisait de même master que nous mais
à dakar
et là aussi on n'a pas été déçu ah ils
nous ont reçus en costume trois pièces
n'hésitez pas aux coupes désastre et on
était presque perturbé parce que je
pense vraiment qu'on n'était pas à la
hauteur ce jour là et ils nous ont pris
à individuellement et collectivement et
sont rappelés systématiquement afin de
les conversations étaient mais cédric on
est ensemble systématique très fort il
répétait souvent on est ensemble et puis
ces quinze jours c'était vraiment une
parenthèse enchantée dans ma vie m'a
permis de remettre un petit peu les les
valeurs où elle devrait être
et je suis rentré en france j'ai couru
après le temps comme vous tous et le
temps fait sujet de ce soir mène la vie
dure à ce que comme nous qui veulent le
tuer je vais continuer mes études et je
suis devenu avocat
pas de vocation bonne presse paraît-il
ça dépend c'est une profession qui m'est
cher parce que non seulement c'est la
mienne mais elle m'est tombé dessus avec
avec beaucoup d évidence cette violence
est ce que je voulais faire c'était
accompagner les les chutes et des
ascensions et ce jour là on a fait un
repas avec deux amis africains
le jour de la prestation de serment deux
amis que je connais c'est qu'ils ne se
connaissaient pas michel haut niveau à
rien et issifou qu un togolais et tous
les trois ont prêté serment et est
finalement on a on a échangé on a fait
un petit apéritif
après une prestation cernon et j'ai
voulu parce que je ne suis pas afrique
savoir ce qu'ils pensaient de leur leur
pays de leur continent - il m'avait
marqué et tous les deux ils ont eu des
réponses tout à fait différente
michel c'est le pessimiste michelle il
avait un petit peu honte ce qui se passe
en afrique aujourd'hui et me dit tu
sèmes 10 et on pourra rien en faire
l'afrique c'est la corruption des élites
c'est le secteur informel et qui est sûr
développer des gens ne déclare rien il
ya vraiment énormément de problèmes les
jeunes n'arrivent pas à s'en sortir
précisément parce que les états souvent
je dirais entretiennent souvent des
corruptions et des intermédiaires sont
excessivement compliqué à gérer
l'administratif et une pesanteur
terrible et me dit je vois l'avenir de
façon assez sombre il disait des choses
assez juste somme toute et je n'étais
pas complètement d accord avec lui et
puis derogy si fou quel est ton avis
immédiat
alors moi je veux pas tout à fait
d'accord moi je suis complètement fous
de mon continent dire on a le ce lien ce
respect de la hiérarchie le respect des
anciens totems qui va être abordée
mdi c'est vrai que chez nous il ya un
sentiment de fraternité très fort on a
tendance à faire confiance tout un petit
peu rapidement et c'est vrai qu'il me
dise sont là aussi des valeurs que je ne
retrouve pas systématiquement europe et
dit michel tu devrais pas avoir honte du
continent tu verras on va s'en sortir et
on est ensemble on ne s'inquiète pas et
puis bon chemin faisant le nos routes se
sont un petit peu séparés j'ai prêté
serment
je suis devenu j'ai défendu au début des
criminels et puis petit à petit mon
exercice a un peu évolué j'ai défendu
des sociétés qui étaient souvent en lien
avec les technologies je me suis associé
au sein du cabinet j'ai animé un
département qui s'appelait nouvelles
technologies blocs chaîne un bloc shell
alors au début
au début c'est un client qui m'a invité
à créer ce pôle la jetée sur c'est le
futur c'est quoi la bloquer c'est simple
ça enregistre un registre décentralisée
distribués qui fonctionne avec les
cryptographique asymétrique
je ne comprenais pas un seul des mots
qui qualifié la notion de blocage et
finalement monsieur tu verras c'est
assez simple du registre aigu des
centres les yeux que les chronos il ya
des mineurs du nord mais tu peu après
l'une des applications c'était le
bitcoin mais le bitcoin a fait sensation
c'est une des applications du logiciel
globale que les blocages allaient
bloquer chaîne permet beaucoup de choses
ça permet de transférer une idée de
stocker des actifs et une information
quelle qu'elle soit j'arrive toujours
pas à comprendre complètement ce
qu'était la technologie et est ce que
est ce que certains d'entre vous
connaissent la bloquer
est ce que c'est un trou ont déjà
entendu plus ou moins si on vous demande
d'expliquer être un peu compliqué dîners
en ville c'est pas parce que plus facile
et bon ma compréhension un peu évolué au
gré de mes lectures et
quelques clients ce sont sont venus à
moi le premier c'est un jeune médecin
polytechnicien vannes ou deux ans mais
qu'à ses brillants et me dit m j'ai un
logiciel qui permet de tracer les
médicaments et d'éviter qu'ils soient
corrompus
je m'explique il me dit plus de sept
médicaments sur dix en afrique sont des
faux médicaments
sept médicaments sur dix nouveaux wc
d'études officiel de l'om est il me dit
d'appeler j'ai vu de mes yeux vu unis de
lamoura dans certains certains
médicaments et il me dit ça m'a ça m'a
traumatisée et donc je veux avec un
logiciel scanne un médicament qui n'est
pas contrefaits petit bonhomme vert
médicament qui est contrefait petit
bonhomme rouge fantastique lui dis-je
c'est quoi ça marche comment ton truc la
technologie blu qui commençait à devenir
intéressant ensuite autre client n'a eu
entre-temps évidemment heureusement pour
nous autres clients et deuxième client
il dit - m j'ai la solution pour
éradiquer la fraude aux élections
lui c'est très simple vous mettez en
place un protocole tous les partis
s'accordent sur le protocole tout est
tracé
tout est inscrit dans un grand registre
et il ne peut pas avoir de fraude
électorale
plus de fraudes plus de fraudes plus
pappas plus de paperasse plus de
contestation du ballon tout est écrit
sur le registre le registre c'est quoi
la prochaine à moins un peu magique mais
réellement ça avait une utilité
troisième client cette fois ci une ong
lorenzi me dit m vous savez combien
coûte la fraude la corruption en afrique
jamais véritablement intéressé aux
chiffres l'arithmétique et du corps mon
plaisir comme disait mon grand maître je
ne compte pas mdi 142 milliard 140 de
mire et me dit vous savez combien il y
ades en afrique
sinon une 10 ans 48 milliards donc il me
dit chaque fois qu'on investit un euro
en gros un peu de choses près le même
euro se dissout à la faveur de la
corruption et me dit moi j'ai une
solution assez précises qui permet de
débloquer les fonds
une fois que on est certain que le
projet est avancé ça permet de tracer
des fonds et d'éviter qu'il y ait des
intermédiaires qui capte les flux il me
dit moi j'ai vu mais je m'en souvenais
de cette expérience
des associations se faire inquiéter
véritablement à l'entrée des villages
alors ce qu'elle allait aider les
populations j'ai trouvé ça
particulièrement scandaleux dit non mais
on peut on peut arriver à gérer ça assez
bien assez facilement d'ailleurs celui
d'envoyer des fonds et de le débloquer
de façon automatique à travers un
contrat intelligent auprès de smart
contracte moi je connaissais un petit
peu la notion whaou
et ça ça c'est la bloquer c'est
intéressant et la durée et depuis on
peut presque plus que ça on accompagne
les clients dans la transformation et on
a refait un repas avec michel et issifou
et je leur ai parlé cette fois ci j'ai
pris un petit peu à part dans les genres
expliquer tout cela et on a convenu
ensemble que bon un propos banal mais qu
un des problèmes en afrique c'est
effectivement la confiance et que si on
arrivait à résoudre ce problème a donné
envie non seulement en afrique mais
également au monde entier d'y investir
d'implanter des sociétés de mieux
éduquer les populations
eh ben on arriverait à véritablement à
faire de ce continent
une absolue merveille parce qu'on
garderait les valeurs et on améliorerait
finalement cette crise de confiance
actuelle et il n'y a pas aujourd'hui une
technologie
meilleur que la blocs chaîne pour
révolutionner justement cette crise de
confiance
on a partagé ce constat le pessimisme
était un peu moins optimiste lui était
évidemment un peu inquiets des
conséquences écologiques des protocoles
actuels parce qu'il faut en parler c'est
un vrai problème
on pense que la technologie va évoluer
c'est ça la bloquer c'est ça ça permet
de régler cette crise de confiance et
c'est vrai que et c'est vrai que c'est
tellement merveilleux et que le futur
peut arriver à mon avis plus vite que
prévu et qu'on surestime souvent la
vitesse à laquelle vont les choses où
vont les choses ça on surestime mais en
sous-estimant revanche l'impact à long
terme de cette technologie de cette
révolution
souvent silencieuse parce qu'on s'en
rend pas forcément compte c'est de ça
dont je vais vous parler ce soir la
confiance maintenant tout de suite pour
l'afrique et pour longtemps
merci l'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]